Cuáles son las presiones de lado y lado
que enfrenta Joe biden en cuanto a la
migración y que tanto margen de maniobra
tiene realmente en Texas
Buenas tardes María Clara bueno las
condiciones políticas en donde el
presidente va a ir en se tiene que
que enfocar van a ser bastante
complicadas precisamente por esa
división dentro del de la republicana
que realmente no tiene las intenciones
nunca ha tenido las intenciones y veo
muy difícil que tenga las intenciones en
poder ayudar o soportar esas políticas
que el presidente va a iren y otros
presidentes anteriores han dicho en
relación a la migración y regular a la
migración hacia los Estados Unidos y que
prácticamente estamos más de 25 años
esperando una reforma migratoria que
lamentablemente no se va a hacer
realidad en esta administración al menos
debido precisamente a lo que ya hemos
visto en los primeros días con el nuevo
congreso republicano y por qué lo están
criticando dentro de su propio partido
los demócratas
Bueno lo critican porque en su momento
él había indicado de que se va a alzar
todas las restricciones así lo hizo pero
hemos visto también que la injerencia
por parte del tribunal supremo acá en el
en Estados Unidos ha provocado de que
las políticas que se suponía que iban al
ser suspendidas de la terminación del
título cuarenta y dos principalmente
no se lleven a cabo por la presión
política de los distintos gobernadores
de los de los estados fronterizos en
donde realmente son ellos los que están
viviendo una presión gigantesca por la
crisis humanitaria que nosotros estamos
viviendo en todas las fronteras en todas
las frontera sur de Estados Unidos y en
la frontera norte de México en la
frontera entre Guatemala y México en las
fronteras del Darién Y por supuesto en
distintos países de la región que
lamentablemente miran como la migración
irregular
ensangrentan las fronteras pero que no
encuentran o no quieren buscar
soluciones a largo plazo para esta
situación insostenible en la región y
precisamente a propósito del título 42
que usted Menciona biden amplió un poco
las medidas al cambiar las políticas
migratorias y advertir que deportará a
venezolanos haitianos nicaragüenses y
cubanos que no entren con una
autorización y dice que los deportara a
México pero tiene este país la capacidad
de albergarlos a todos
tiene la capacidad para recibirlos pero
no para albergarlo tiene la capacidad
para poder
darles
oportunidades a las mafias
internacionales para que los secuestren
para que los violen para que los
desaparezcan pero no existe nosotros no
hemos visto y por supuesto la ciudadanía
Tampoco no hemos visto políticas
públicas por parte del gobierno mexicano
que vayan en defensa de los migrantes o
de las familias más bien hemos visto un
desinterés cuando vemos que hay niños
que se mueren en el río hay mujeres que
son violentadas hay hombres que son
secuestrados y que a la larga lo que no
es simplemente una nueva reunión entre
líderes que solo se ponen a hablar y no
ejecutar soluciones